quel est notre identité génétique si
demain le gigantesque effort mondial
fait par des chercheurs internationaux
permet de répondre à cette question sans
doute des dizaines peut-être des
centaines de maladies pourront être
combattue efficacement on est bien sûr
très loin du compte encore mais la
publication aujourd'hui dans la revue
scientifique britannique nature du
décryptage de la structure d'un
chromosome humain est un énorme pas en
avant
le jeune homme humain est composé de 23
paires de chromosomes chaque chromosome
contient des centaines de milliers de
jeunes qui en aurait entre 80 et 100
mille gènes répertoriés certains sont
défectueux ils sont à l'origine
d'environ 8000 maladies et pas seulement
des myopathies mais aussi certaines
formes de cancer notamment ces quelques
chiffres donnent la mesure du travail
entrepris par les chercheurs sachez par
exemple que le chromosome qui vient
d'être décrypté contient plusieurs
centaines de gènes explications jean
daniel flaysakier ce drôle l'hippocampe
est en fait de l'adn c'est à dire le
programme qui gère dès la conception la
vie de chacun d'entre nous hormis les
globules rouges chaque cellules de notre
corps contient un maître de cet adn sous
la forme de 23 paires de chromosomes ou
tabous cela fait plus de 100 milliards
de kilomètres aujourd'hui des chercheurs
britanniques viennent de réussir à
déchiffrer le message d'un de ses
chromosomes
le numéro 22 un peu comme s'ils avaient
décoder un des 23 volume du manuel de
fonctionnement de notre corps
et ce petit chromosomes et très
intéressant à connaître car ils portent
des gènes impliqués dans une trentaine
de malades
l'une d'entre elles est le syndrome de
di george dans cette maladie génétique
existe des troubles du développement
chez l'enfant portant notamment sur le
langage
ce syndrome serait à l'origine d'un
certain nombre de retards scolaires
c'est dire si les généticiens accueille
ce décryptage du chromosome 22 avec
intérêt la connaissance des gènes qui
sont véritablement impliqué dans ce
syndrome pour un de donner
éventuellement des outils pour
comprendre pourquoi c'est ce retard de
langage ses difficultés mise en place de
du développement verbal des enfants
existe et peut-être peut-être de de
formuler des hypothèses thérapeutiques
plus approprié que celle que nous
manions actuellement qui sont des
rééducations général du langage dans les
mois qui viennent la plupart des autres
promos zones seront eux aussi des
chiffres et il faudra analyser alors
chaque gène pour comprendre comment ils
fonctionnent quand il est normal et
quand il est malade
en attendant enfin le jour où on saura
réparer les pannes sur les chromosomes
défaillir l'aisne